[Music]
each pin on this map marks the location
of an attack on black americans and
their communities from the civil war
into the 1900s
it's no accident you're unlikely to find
many of these in american history
textbooks there's been a concerted
effort to whitewash and cover many of
them up
but while some of the stories may have
been scrubbed from the records and
textbooks throughout history survivors
and their descendants are speaking out
shedding light on the violent events
that took place in their communities and
exposing the lingering social and
economic damage caused by some of the
worst racial violence in american
history
[Music]
after the american civil war the country
entered a period known as reconstruction
during which it set about reintegrating
the confederate states and nearly four
million newly freed enslaved people
but african americans were hardly given
a foundation on which to build their new
lives after the war
no reparations were paid to the formerly
enslaved for what they and their
families had endured for generations
many had been told they'd be given a
small plot of land to get started on and
while there were plans to allocate some
land to the formerly enslaved after the
war such as special field order number
15 much of the land seized by union
forces or promised african americans was
later given back to white southern
citizens ex-slave owners and to white
northern entrepreneurs the following
decades saw african-americans slowly
gain more economic and political power
they bought land started businesses and
built schools but in many places where
african americans succeeded
white americans set out to destroy that
success
the civil war was a revolution it
destroyed the most powerful slave owning
class in the world and now the question
is what's going to replace it
the freed people had a clear
understanding of what their freedom
meant they wanted self-determination
they wanted to reconstitute their
families they wanted to live as far away
from white people as they could they
basically wanted to be left alone but
they also wanted to be citizens and they
wanted to exercise the rights that other
citizens did and so
on some level reconstruction
was designed to answer this question
about the meaning of freedom and so
african americans became citizens
slaveries abolished for the 13th
amendment the 14th amendment
nationalizes citizenship and creates due
process and so now black people have
equal protection before the law and they
can now run for office hold office and
participate in society it succeeded for
a brief time that it existed black
people were running for election they
were holding office
there were integrated schools
we were beginning to act and behave like
a democracy by 1877 as the north tires
of reconstruction we see the withdrawal
of troops and on some level really the
withdrawal of federal protection of
black people's rights
just because the federal government said
reconstruction was over did mean that
black people stopped living their lives
like free people they continued to hold
office they continued to form these very
important biracial political parties and
movements they joined interracial unions
they began to own businesses some cases
owning land extraordinary success in the
face of a lot of violence and not much
federal protection but what happens in
the 1890s is that the southern elite
decides for themselves what the meaning
of freedom is going to be they're going
to strip black people of their
citizenship white supremacy is
reconstituted in the 1890s it can't look
the same as it did in slavery and so
what you end up with is disfranchisement
and segregation
and sharecropping and combat labor and
debt peonage but underwriting that is
extraordinary violence and terror
[Music]
i like this phrase that sociologists
historians often use to describe the
country in terms of race relations and
that is that this was a period
they described as the nader of race
relations in america the low point of
race relations in america and they use
that language because there was this
proliferation of these events that were
called race riots that were mainly
assault on black communities it was in
new york in philadelphia baltimore and
memphis and omaha and chicago and d.c
summer in fall of 1919 was dubbed by
james weldon johnson who was with the
naacp as red summer red is a
metaphorical reference to blood that
flowed through the streets from all this
violence post world war one the other
thing that's happening during this
period is lynching lynching is simply a
form of domestic terrorism aimed more
often than not at black folks the real
aim is to strike fear in the hearts and
minds of a group black folks in this
case to make sure that black folks knew
and stayed in their place and so
lynching
was
running rampant during this period
the elaine that we see today is very
different from the elaine at the time of
the massacre at the time of the massacre
it was one of the fastest growing cities
and local economies in the state the
bulk of this new revenue that was
coming in was from cotton sales cotton
is at the heart of understanding what
happened during the elaine massacre
first of all there are sharecroppers the
official name for it is debt panic on
its surface it seems very very fair
planters offer plots of their land to
share croppers in exchange for their
labor the way the system is supposed to
work is at the end of the growing season
the profits from the harvest are
supposed to be split 50 50. half going
to the planter the other half going to
the laborer however
this isn't what normally happened
there's an inherent problem when you
have a planter that has to go a whole
growing season and he has no income you
have to ask yourself how does he survive
and he survives by borrowing from the
planter and this is where the plantation
store comes into play every plantation
had a plantation store
its sharecroppers could go to that store
and get items on credit
what most people don't know is that the
credit offered at this store was at
astronomical rates even when the
sharecropper received his half of the
shares quite often because of these
doctored books
and these inflated prices he was never
able to get out of debt and therefore he
really could not leave because he owed
money what sharecropping or debt peonage
did was enable planters to have a
workforce that they virtually paid
nothing for the planters would sell the
cotton and quite often come back and say
well this is all i got for it and pay
the sharecropper only a fraction of the
half that he was supposed to get this
kept them in perpetual debt and with the
judicial system that was not going to
allow them to leave the debt hanging the
sharecroppers were in essence made
slaves african-americans had just gone
off to war so many african-americans who
would participate in a war were given
promises that if they went and fought
this war they returned as a full-fledged
citizen so when they returned to these
cotton fields and they find themselves
being cheated just as they had before
they believe that they have recourse and
the recourse that they believe they have
now is the courts they band together
form a union hire an attorney and this
will be their undoing once the planters
find out
the last evening of september
of 1919 there is a meeting called for
the progressive farmers and household
union this was the union that the
sharecroppers had formed to sue the
plantation owners for their rights
plantation owners got wind that these
meetings were happening they send out
bands of people who are also sheriffs
and law enforcement but also individuals
who work on those plantations are sort
of overseers there's a shooting that
occurs right outside of one of the
meetings
two of the individuals
who have been sent there by the planters
to the law enforcement agents one is
injured and one is killed and when the
report gets out of the shooting those
individuals that had gone there harassed
the meeting will begin passing on
messages that are totally unfounded at
that point that there was an
insurrection going to take place and
that this insurrection was intended to
overthrow the county and displace
a white rule there the response to that
report will be that hundreds of
individuals will pour in from
neighboring counties the white american
legion that had just been established
before would be deputized these men are
sent out to arrest the union members and
there's a shootout when they return and
try to arrest them from dc orders will
come to the governor and to military
bases there that 500 troops would be
mobilized and sent in by the federal
government even though the sharecroppers
are arrested this isn't enough to stop
the mobs that are have already been
called in they begin shooting at
any black person that they saw many
blacks will begin hiding in the swamps
or hiding in thickets these men and
small groups will begin hunting them out
they saw the military trains
arrive and when
the troops came looking
for blacks they assumed that they were
there to help them so blacks began
coming out of the woods
and going toward the soldiers and were
shot down some of them by machine
gunners the governor himself raced over
in a car to try to be there for the
photo ops and to participate my
grandfather said uh they were
surrounding people and they was uh you
know shooting birds and asking questions
even with women and children they lost
friends in the massacre because all of
them stayed in the area and when people
came they were just shooting everybody
they wasn't you got a scene you got shot
everything was
just shoot to kill shoot to kill
and then i was told that when they had
killed the black a ditch was
dug and they all were thrown into that
ditch as one big lump sum not a grave
not a burial but all were thrown in a
ditch their homes were formerly slave
cabins that are on the property or
shanties that had been largely
established by the planters and weren't
owned by them what we see is looting of
these cabins the taking of the the
little livestock they have and the
taking of property that belonged to them
we do not know how many people were
killed there has never been a single
grave that has been discovered or
recovered people had to make a conscious
decision whether you stayed and you
continued to work or whether you fled
and a great number of people fled after
this event
according to some descendants as
residents fled the town and surrounding
phillips county they were forced to
leave behind land they owned which was
then stolen by white residents some of
whom perpetrated the massacre while
evidence of black land ownership in and
around a lane from the time period has
been difficult to find some black
descendants claim that's because a lot
of the documents were likely destroyed
what is clear is that a consistent oral
history of land theft has been passed
down through generations of black
residents of phillips county
we ain't got no proof
but we do have the oil stores and if you
listen to the oil stores all of them
assisted you know people can't make this
stuff up you know if you listen to these
stories you cannot make this stuff
the families of plantation owners have
made themselves considerably wealthy
from the cotton boom that took place
there and the generations that were able
to either exploit uh slavery
or exploit black labor through that pnh
but
there was no profit and there was no
gain for these the individuals who
actually were out there doing the work
and now like uh the old hedge clippers
they've all been discarded and forgotten
left behind
and that's where
uh elaine is today it has some of the
highest poverty rates in the country
high unemployment rates it's riddled
with health issues poor drinking water
there is no school in the town they have
to bust their children out it's a lot of
money here but there's no generation
well for black people when the killing
was over
all the way up for black people
just went away
going to elaine is like going to the end
of the world
there's only one way in and one way out
[Music]
one of the ironies about oklahoma is
that it comes late into statehood 1907
and it had been promoted even by black
folks as kind of a promised land a
beulah land a land of opportunity
because it had not come into statehood
and there were diverse folks here
including natives there were calls for
black folks to come to oklahoma to get
away from the deep south and the rigid
segregation that existed there tulsa
really transitioned from sort of a dusty
western outpost
to a much more
a cosmopolitan
city at the turn of the 20th century
primarily attributable to the discovery
of oil tulsa was a segregated city
as were many cities during this period
the black community sat just north of
the frisco tracks black folks were
segregated into this geographic area but
they actually leveraged segregation to
create an economic enclave that was very
successful because
folks were
based on the constraint of segregation
forced to to trade with and do business
with one another it became an enclave
of
not just entrepreneurs and business
folks but a bunch of professionals
doctors lawyers dentists accountants etc
and there were economic successes
throughout the country
in these segregated black neighborhoods
and and some beyond
the confines of segregation
oklahoma in the run-up to statehood
becomes really a bastion of the same
kind of of white supremacist notions
that existed in the deep south the
massacre was caused by a number of
things the greenwood district the black
community in tulsa sat on land that was
desired by industrialists including
railroad executives we also have to
think about white supremacy and and the
psychological dynamics that were
operative not just in tulsa but
throughout the united states in tulsa
you have kind of an extreme example
because you have
black wealth in this segregated
community that abuts downtown tulsa
white tulsa if you're a white person you
could literally stand on the frisco
tracks and look over into north tulsa
and see black folks who were driving
nice cars owning their own homes having
their own businesses
and that was
in my estimation the cause for
cognitive dissonance black folks were
faring much better economically
in tulsa than many white folks thought
they should be another factor was the
kkk
the ku klux klan
an iconic domestic terrorist
organization which had a foothold in
oklahoma throughout the 1920s tulsa was
no exception add to that the media
one particular media outlet called the
tulsa tribune a daily afternoon
newspaper published a series of
incendiary articles and editorials that
really fermented hostility in the white
community against the black community
during the run-up to the massacre and
that's the context those are the
atmospherics
of tulsa um as we talk about may 31st
and june 1st the days of
the massacre
the incident began with an elevator
incident there was a black boy whose
name was dick rowland 19 years old who
shines shoes for a living he needed to
use the restroom one morning this is may
30th facilities available for his use
were were limited because of segregation
he knew that there was such a facility
on the third floor the downtown drexel
building has to take the elevator up to
the third floor
elevators back then are manually
operated a young white girl named sarah
page is manually operating this elevator
something happened on the elevator we
don't know exactly what it was we'll
never know likely but it likely was that
he bumped into a brush up against sarah
page some say stepped on her foot in any
event she overreacted she began
screaming
the elevator landed back in the lobby
dick rowland frightens
as well he probably should be given the
circumstances frightened ran from the
elevator
sarah page is distraught she
exits the elevator she's comforted by a
clerk from renberg's which is locally
owned store he's concerned about her she
talks about being assaulted on the
elevator he calls the police
she ultimately recants the original
story refuses to cooperate prosecutors
after dick rowland has been arrested
unfortunately
by the time the recantation occurs it's
too late it's too late in part because
the tulsa tribune
published an article the next day it's
entitled nab negro for attacking girl in
an elevator painting it as an attempted
rape in broad daylight
there's language in that article that
clearly is intended to make sarah paige
look more virtuous the the corollary
effect of which is to make dick roam
look more villainous and it has its
desired effect a large mob of white men
began to gather
dick rowland had been arrested by this
time by the sheriff put in jail which
set atop the
courthouse white men gathered on the
lawn of the courthouse
ultimately the white mob numbered in the
thousands
the sheriff was so concerned that he
actually called down to the offices of
the tulsa star the black newspaper he
knew that there would be a black men
gathered there
and told him
what had transpired that the grown was
arrested that he was being
uh held in jail that he was safe he's
been protected but he was concerned
because he was hearing this lynch talk
among this large
and growing white mob
a number of black men several dozen in
number some of them world war one
veterans with weapons who knew how to
use them marched down to the courthouse
intent on protecting dick rowland from
what they thought would be a certain
lynching they were confronted by the
larger white mob
as you might imagine words were
exchanged a white man tried to take a
black man's gun and got discharged
and in the words of
some of the massacre survivors all
hellbrook was after that
the so-called riot was on and it
resulted in the devastation of the
greenwood community many people in the
white mob many of these men were
actually deputized by local law
enforcement
they affirmatively prevented the fire
department from putting out the fires
that raged planes flew over the
greenwood community privately on planes
and according to eyewitness dropped
incendiary devices bombs on the
community that caused the flames to burn
more brilliantly and spread more rapidly
the national guard was ultimately called
in to quell the violence which they did
on the afternoon of june 1st 1921 the
next day
[Music]
the official death toll is 37. nobody
who's studied these events believes that
to be true it's more likely within a
range of 100 to 300. at least 1250 homes
in the black community were destroyed as
well as were a number of churches
schools business places and other
commercial establishments the red cross
provided relief immediately post
massacre food shelter clothing by all
accounts did a wonderful job black folks
particularly black men were rounded up
and taken to internment centers
throughout the city for a temporary
period it was ostensibly for their own
protection but according to survivors it
left the community
essentially defenseless and unprotected
so looters came in and pillaged homes of
finery like jewelry and expensive items
that some of the more wealthy residents
of the community had owned
[Music]
the tulsa and elaine massacres were not
isolated incidents they were just two of
many and they were representative of a
broad backlash to the social status of
black people in the united states the
goal of attacks like these historians
say was to maintain white supremacy by
any means necessary and the effects of
these attacks on black communities can
still be seen and felt today you know
some people say well slavery ended years
ago or even you know segregation ended
years ago
you know that's in the past why are you
dredging up the past well the past isn't
the past and i think my whole body of
research that i've done looking at
different events all across the world
you find this over and over and over
that the effects of the past linger and
they have consequences and in general if
these events are historically important
enough they'll that they shape uh the
way the world is today after learning
about the tulsa massacre and reading a
bit about it and realizing we don't have
a lot of hard statistical evidence about
what the consequences were that's
basically where i came in is just
wanting to know what were the
consequences of the tulsa massacre so
immediately after the massacre we find
that black household heads who owned
homes fell by 4.5 percentage points and
then if you think of another measure of
that is are you an individual that's
living in a home that's owned by someone
in your family that measure of
homeownership fell by 6.3 percentage
points
and the other thing that we find is
decline in
occupational status and one measure of
occupational status is to look at is an
individual working in a white collar
occupation there's a 3.1 percent chance
that you're in a white-collar occupation
then after the massacre that figure
falls by 2.3 percentage points so that's
a huge huge effect it's uh you know 66
percent decline in white-collar
occupations that result is controlling
for taking into account everything else
that's going on in the economy and also
between different racial groups but it's
not just in tulsa but we see these
effects in other parts of the country as
well so we look at newspapers all across
the u.s and basically look and see are
they covering the massacre in the days
right after and what we find is where
there is more intensity of coverage
about the massacre the effects that we
find in tulsa we also find in those
communities as well
just like we know that there's a thing
such as generational wealth there's also
generational poverty what we found in
working through the jessica greenwood
foundation and our work with our
survivors and descendants is that this
generational poverty or generational
lack of opportunity started with the
massacre and let's talk about viable
fletcher after the massacre and mother
fletcher had to flee for her life with
her family to claremore to live in an
impoverished state she was not able to
go back and finish school and it caused
her lots of problems in life for most of
her life she was a domestic worker
working for pennies working for white
families that treated her
less than they treated their dogs
you know leslie benefield randall
also a little girl at the time only six
years old but she was in town with her
her grandmother molly benefiel and
obviously doing her massacre she's a
young lady she said she can't remember a
lot but she does remember running she
does remember them coming to the door
saying get the blacks need to get it out
the white people are killing all the
black particularly the black men she
remembers being taken to the fairgrounds
which is one of the places they put our
our people in those what they called at
the time concentration camps
uh hughes vanellos we call him uncle red
and obviously he was a baby he was an
infant uh at the time of the mask i
think he was six months old hughes van
ellis and biola fletcher are brother and
sister they live
a lot of his childhood
outside i mean they basically lived in
like a tent they they basically had to
survive off off the land and it was very
traumatizing for him and something that
shaped his life a 2018 study from the
american journal of economics and
sociology estimated that if 1 200 median
priced houses in tulsa were destroyed
today the loss would be around 150
million dollars the additional loss of
other assets including cash personal
belongings and commercial property might
bring the total to over 200 million
dollars
[Music]
so the grammar community as a business
community was destroyed as a testament
to the to the resilience and the
endowment human spirit that was endemic
in the community the community was fully
rebuilt
began to really
boom peaking in the early to mid 1940s
that continued throughout the 50s began
to decline in the 60s and 70s for a
couple of reasons that are really
important to the story if you want to
connect 1921 to the present at the macro
level one of the major things that
happened was integration found its way
to tulsa the greenwood community as a
business community was successful
largely because
it was a closed market which was
attributed to
the jim crow laws that existed so
because of segregation there was a need
for
a greenwood community black folks
couldn't get what they needed or
couldn't apply their trades
in the larger dominant white community
so they created their own economic space
even the black folks that work outside
the community bring their dollars
ultimately back in the community that
begins to change
when the world begins to change because
of integration so black dollars then
have another outlet
it's hard for
a sole proprietor a mom-and-pop type
small business in the agreement
community to compete with walmart
that opening up ironically has the
economic effect of undermining the
success of the black community when the
black community begins to decline
because of integration and other
systemic factors there's a movement in
the 60s and 70s
designed ostensibly to address blighted
communities
called urban renewal so you see a
blighted community
you come in with urban renewal
and you buy up the land
and you take away the properties
so what then you get is black folks
losing their businesses
losing the land and really struggling so
today what we have in the greenwood
community is
a community that is actually bustling
but it's not a community in which black
folks own the most of the land
[Music]
the pins on this map mark just some of
the more well documented attacks on
black communities from the civil war
into the 1900s but it doesn't include
the countless other assaults on black
communities during this time period from
countless lynchings to entire black
communities being expelled from their
towns by white mobs the scale of damage
here is in many ways incalculable
families torn apart communities
destroyed and generational wealth erased
like many other communities impacted by
these type of racist attacks throughout
history black residents of tulsa and
elaine are still looking for justice and
some semblance of closure i would love
to know what happened to my people or my
family and if i can
figure out what happened to them if i
could get information that would be
great
but i know that they're not going to
give it to us who owes the people that
argument could be had on a lot of
different levels you know the governor
himself participated and asked her so is
the state responsible the governor asked
for federal troops to be sent in is the
federal government responsible is the
local government responsible are
individuals responsible so there's a lot
of blame to throw around in this one one
of the things that makes this difficult
is this lack of bodies but if we're able
to find mass graves and then connect
those bodies to living individuals we
have people who have been harmed and
people that you can pay reparations to
when i think about reparations i i think
of the denotation of the term what does
the term actually mean it means to make
amends or to repair damage the
fundamental question is is there
damage
in this community that is in need of
repair that we can trace back to 1921. i
don't know anybody who wouldn't who
could answer no to that question the
hard part is really talking through
the nature of the damage
and in terms of remediation
what things work best that's the only
way
we can get back to where we were
if we get that reparations restitution
remedy whatever words you want to use a
comprehensive plan that provides a
remedy and benefit to those who suffered
the harm there could be targeted
economic investments in the black
community the community most harmed by
the massacre curriculum reform the whole
point of curriculum reform is to include
this history as an integral part of the
curriculum such that the errors of the
past are not made again and such that
people specifically black people
see themselves reflected in ways that
that embolden them
and give them the psychological power
to be creators and entrepreneurs in the
present without history
we don't have a true understanding of
our nation particularly our nation's
most marginalized communities somehow we
need to be able to present this history
as our history and to help people
understand that you're not responsible
for the past i'm not responsible for
what my ancestors did but i'm obligated
to the present to do what i can to make
things better
[Music]
you